I'm feeling so defeated I'm doing so bad
at this
yeah you are oh my god hi I'm Danny
and I'm sorry and we've been best
friends since we met and now we live
together and we're trying to make less
food waste I try my best to live zero
waste and not make class of trash but I
think I need to take a hard look at the
food waste that I create
I just love things that are convenient
the world's burning we gotta do better
each week we're going to be emptying out
our fridge and weighing all the food we
wasted to keep ourselves more
accountable this is such a privilege
issue it really is just like oh nice
this food all right these lemon bars
that are definitely no good anymore but
we can recycle it's in number six that
probably actually won't get recycled
really yes this is my fault
this is pasola oh this is the meat
that's probably not good anymore where
did these avocados looks my fault
without a weed chop the fire we're gonna
weigh the food waste from our fridge
from this week oh four pounds 13 ounces
you did good I don't know it's it's okay
we're gonna try to do better
four pounds hopefully to zero pounds yes
or like maybe one ounce because I'm
person we're seeing if anything needs to
be eaten in here no I mean maybe some
cilantro I already ate some of the vegan
mac and cheese that's what I'm gonna
have for dinner
oh no you told me you're gonna have some
I have all these grand plans of all the
meals I'm gonna make but then I work
full time and then things slip through
the cracks and I end up wasting food I
got these leftovers from a restaurant
and look at me I'm late anyway three I
put it in a jar but then I didn't eat it
and so I wasted it I'm at my boyfriend's
house because I'm in and out so much
I've wasted this it's been about a week
and it's looking sad there was some sad
looking carrots and spinach in the
fridge so I made them into soup this is
not good
doesn't smell bad but it's not good this
wash is mine you know what bad oh this
is bad
what is this Oh - it looks like all of
us heard this is our isse I mean she
wasted an entire thing of milk I was
gonna make yogurt and then it didn't
happen I made a soup and it got old yeah
you know I thought we were gonna do
better yeah let's go stressed me out
[Music]
that milks really adding some poundage
just saying yep all right let's see if
you - the way to the bowl we wasted 5.4
1/2 of wet here's to not sucking next
week you can do it you do it here is our
compost which we keep so this other food
weighs we actually can compost when food
scraps go into a trash can they get
suffocated in a plastic bag and then
they go to a landfill where they off gas
methane which is a greenhouse gas so
composting food scraps and food waste is
a way to keep methane out of our
environment it's hard like rememory and
even just like getting things in
styrofoam and I know that that's not
like the purpose of this challenge is
challenges to not waste food but then
might get it in styrofoam to like save
it and then I'm just like creating
double ways and I just kind of feel like
oh my god I really wanted to go out to
lunch with my friend but instead I'm
gonna eat these leftovers yeah Ahri's
nasty as hell
look at this what is this why I made a
fridge soup with all the odds and ends
vegetables that I had leftover in my
fridge and it's pretty tasty right ready
this is a sandwich here
Oh went really bad
I wasted these mushrooms you always
waste mushroom I bet it's a problem
waste of the salmon well it smells
really bad it's only am a pound I think
we have gotten better though yeah I just
made some nut milk and then with the nut
milk pulp from the cheesecloth
I made some dope granola bars and Pepita
meal I'm gonna use this Paquita meal to
make a vegan deconstructed ratatouille
instead of wasting as a very old banana
I'm freezing it and I'm gonna use it for
some smoothies my goal tonight is to
have a little dinner of hodgepodge
leftovers to eat tacos so let's look at
my damage remember this guy got these
ice creams those really stoned
technically you haven't really wasted
much I wasted Mikado and these yellow
squash that is nine ounces of waste okay
my house is always like this is really
hard
dj khaled was right they don't want us
to win but you know we're gonna win
because we are taking steps to being
better and it's not about being perfect
it's about taking steps to be better I
totally agree such a privilege to be
able to have in to waste this challenges
made me expand the way that I cook kind
of make food stretch my mom would be
really proud of me yes like Aliya can
afro-latino mom she'd be like wow my god
it's good it's good you don't wasting
[ __ ] today